Writer/director James Gunn's upcoming soft
reboot The Suicide Squad will likely be missing
the original's most divisive element.
In a recent Q&A conducted on Instagram, Gunn
appeared to shoot down the idea of Jared Leto's
Joker appearing in his film in response to
a question from a fan.
Gunn was asked:
"How can you justify a Suicide Squad movie
that does not have Joker in it?"
Gunn's response was simple:
"No one but me and a few others know all the
characters in the movie, but if the Joker
isn't in the film, I don't think it would
be strange as he isn't a part of the Suicide
Squad in the comics."
Gunn's absolutely correct that Joker isn't
a part of the Suicide Squad in the comics,
which is one reason why some fans were puzzled
at the character's inclusion in the original
2016 film in the first place.
The version of the Clown Prince of Crime presented
in director David Ayer's Suicide Squad was
just a bit different from the cinematic depictions
of the past, and most DC die-hards agreed
that it was not in a good way.
Leto's Joker's pasty white face and slicked-back,
bright green hair were about the only facets
of the character's physical appearance that
the flick got right.
The platinum grill and tattoos looked absurd
to many fans, and Leto's hyper-stylized, weirdly
off-putting performance did little to quell
their anger when it hit theaters.
"I am not someone who is loved.
I'm an idea.
A state of mind."
Gunn's principal cast for The Suicide Squad
could already fill a good-sized bus.
The cast was revealed last month with the
release of a one-sheet that included a whopping
24 names, featuring both new and returning
cast members.
At this late juncture, it seems pretty unlikely
that Gunn will sneak Leto into the film, and
this latest comment all but confirms the fact
that The Suicide Squad will leave the actor's
version of the Joker out in the cold.
Despite the extremely mixed reception to Leto's
Joker, Suicide Squad made enough bank that
a solo vehicle for the character and a team-up
with Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn were briefly
put into development.
Both of those projects, however, were unceremoniously
axed earlier this year - and that's not even
the strongest indication that Warner Brothers
has completely soured on Leto's version of
the Joker.
Let's not forget that the trailer for the
upcoming Birds of Prey film makes it clear
that, especially as far as Harley Quinn is
concerned, "Mr. J" is out of the picture.
There's also the fact that the standalone,
Joaquin Phoenix -starring Joker movie made
absurd amounts of money, and seems to have
practically guaranteed its star a Best Actor
Oscar nomination.
While it's pretty safe to say that Phoenix's
Joker is going to remain strictly its own
thing, that doesn't mean that Leto was thrilled
about the new film.
Recent reports have indicated that the actor
felt both alienated and upset by the fact
that the movie was even put into development.
Joker's ridiculous success and domination
of the pop culture conversation this fall
probably haven't made Leto feel any better
about the whole thing.
At this point, it's not clear that Leto would
return to the role even if he were asked.
In the meantime, he'll appear as the titular
Living Vampire in next year's Morbius from
Sony and Marvel.
If that film even approaches the box office
heights of Venom, then the Morbius gig could
become a recurring one for Leto.
If Sony and Marvel Studios continue to play
as nice as they have been in the last month
or so, he could even find himself facing off
with Tom Holland's wildly popular Spider-Man.
In any event, it's beginning to look more
and more like Leto's Joker will end up as
a one-and-done, which will suit most fans
just fine.
The Suicide Squad hits the big screen in August,
2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.